let me help you figure out what a
million dollar warning looks like okay
here we go simple rules for a simple
million dollar morning number one when
the alarm rings get your ass out of bed
there's a million reasons not to get out
of bed but Mel it's 30 degrees it's dark
it's raining it's cold it's depressing I
got a lot going on I stayed up late none
of that matters the only thing that
matters is do you keep the promises that
you make to yourself and I know I'm
getting philosophical here we were just
talking about the alarm ringing you know
what the alarm is that alarm when it
goes off that is a promise that you made
you set that alarm didn't you and when
that alarm goes off now it's time to
keep the promise and how do you do that
I'll tell you how do you do that you're
going to use my five second rule the
alarm is going to ring and you are going
to count backwards five four three two
one and then you're just gonna roll out
of bed that's it it's not sexy it's not
fun I have been getting out of bed this
way for 14 years we're taught talking
about the promises that you need to
start to make that are hard and
uncomfortable because you deserve to
have the life that you want and
sometimes feeling like a million bucks
for the whole day means you gotta feel
like for about five seconds and that's
what it's going to take hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because as a young entrepreneur I
struggle to keep my business going I had
no friends I had no mentors I had no
role models and the thing that saved me
was learning from the success stories of
famous entrepreneurs and in their
stories I got motivation and I also got
strategies for what I could do to grow
my business and not stay stuck and I
still need their stories motivation
today so today let's create your million
dollar morning routine enjoy
you wake up
the alarm goes off
the sun is out
you have a brand new day in front of you
there are people around the world that
died in the middle of their sleep last
night they didn't get another day but
you my friend
you got another day
and instead of
waking up getting up making the most of
the next 24 hours of your life you know
what the old Mel Robbins used to do
hey
hitting the snooze button
is
procrastination
in its biggest form
but you're not procrastinating on a
paper
you're not procrastinating on a project
you're not procrastinating on a call or
you're procrastinating on your life
you're basically going
the first decision I'm gonna make today
in this miraculous thing called life
is
to not do it I'm just gonna avoid it all
together I have the option to make the
most of this time I have the option to
put myself first I have the option to
move my body to practice mindfulness to
go outside and listen to the birds but
you know what I think I'm gonna do I
think I'm going to procrastinate I think
I'm going to avoid it I think I'm going
to roll over I think I'm going to just
opt out
and for me I can now see that since the
first decision I made was to avoid doing
what I needed to do
it's so obvious why I was a chronic
procrastinator because I began every day
like that
and as you hit the snooze button and you
avoid facing your life and you avoid
facing the day
you're not feeling confident
you're not feeling energized you're not
feeling in control and empowered you are
basically embodying your excuses your
fears your anxiety your frustration your
fatigue
it all begins with the decision you make
first thing in the morning I believe
that and the reason why I'm being overly
dramatic about this is because one of my
biggest problems in life is that I
avoided the hard stuff I had a million
reasons why I couldn't fix things or get
a new job or pay off my bills or why I
couldn't make things better or why my
husband was to blame and so if you're
sick of your excuses if you're sick of
snoozing on your dreams if you are sick
and tired of letting procrastination and
doubt and overthinking and anxiety run
your life let's talk about your morning
routine because let me tell you what the
life of a chronic snooze button person
looks like
it begins in the morning you hit the
snooze button four or five times that
was me I'd stare at the ceiling think
about my problem snooze snooze and the
rest of the day guess what else I was
doing
snooze snooze on the problems avoiding
the phone call I needed to make that's
hitting the snooze button on that
avoiding the networking I needed to do
that's hitting the snooze button there
avoiding the hard conversation I needed
to have that's hitting the snooze button
they're blowing off the gym another
snooze button it's not just about how
you wake up it's how you wake up how you
set up the day that's how it ends up
the snooze button that is just one
example of the series of disastrous
choices I would make for myself whether
it was hitting the snooze button five or
six times waking up late not giving
myself enough time skipping breakfast
never having time to exercise never
being organized about anything it was
just honestly a nightmare
and I always say you are one decision
away from a different life
and one of the things that has changed
my life is deciding that I didn't want
to do that anymore
that hitting the snooze button every
single morning was not going to help me
change my life rule number two is get
morning sunlight with Andrew huberman so
what's the routine then the ultimate
morning and evening routine to set your
brain and your mind up for Optimal
Performance and not getting brain fog I
generally get up somewhere between
5 30 and 7 in the morning depending on
when I went to sleep I'm not super
regular about when I go to sleep but
generally that's between 10 30 and
midnight yep you're not trying to avoid
that Midnight Hour but
um happens so I get up obviously I use
the restroom I drink some water I do
think that hydrating is very important
yes so I will I'll drink some some water
and then the
fundamental layer of health is to set
your circadian rhythm the simplest way
to do that is to go outside for 10
minutes and get some bright light in
your eyes
I'll just list off some of the things
that people always ask what if you wake
up before the sun rises well simple rule
if you want to be awake turn on as many
bright lights in your house as possible
but then when the Sun goes out it comes
out excuse me get outside and see some
sunlight
you do not have to look directly into
the sun but you do want to get outside
out of shade cover if you can don't wear
sunglasses if you can do that safely
don't try and do this through a window
don't try and negotiate with me on this
point what about a window well the
filtration of the of the important
wavelengths of light through the window
is just too high and so it would take
hours for you to set your circadian
clock that way you want to do this
because once every 24 hours you're going
to get a peak in cortisol which is a
healthy Peak you want that Peak to
happen early in the day because it sets
up alertness for the remainder of the
day there are really nice studies done
by my colleagues in Stanford Psychiatry
and biology Department showing that if
that cortisol Peak starts to drift too
late in the day you start seeing signs
of depression it's actually a well-known
marker of depression so you want that
cortisol almost stressed out kind of the
day's beginning I have a lot to do
feeling that's a healthy thing you want
that happening early in the day the
sunlight will wake you up and what's
really cool is that over time you'll
start to notice the sunlight waking you
up more and more the system becomes
tuned up if you miss a day it's not the
end of the world because it's a as we
call a slow integrating system but don't
miss more than one day and if you live
in an area where it's very cloudy
outside just know that the sunlight the
photons coming through that cloud cover
are brighter than your brightest indoor
lights now if you live in a very dark
region of the world or it's unsafe or
purely impractical to get outside in the
morning then it might make sense to get
a sunrise simulator or one of these
lights but they tend to be very
expensive what I recommend people use
instead is it just a ring light a green
blue light this is a case where you can
blast your system wow so get that
morning light that this is it sets a
number of things in motion such as your
melatonin Rhythm to happen 16 hours
later to help you fall asleep I would
say this is the fundamental
step of any good morning and if you
don't do this enough you are messing
yourself up in a number of ways rule
number three is review your thoughts
with Joe dispenza 86 percent of the
people in the Western World the first
thing they do when they wake up in the
morning is grab their cell phone
it's almost 9 out of 10 people so more
than likely there's a good percentage of
people that are watching this podcast or
listening to it that do that and when
they reach for their cell phone and they
look through their Facebook and their
Instagram and their Tick Tock and their
emails and their Twitter and do all of
that they're connecting to everything
that's known in their life they're
actually making sure that they're
connected in a certain way
in place of that
you can still do that but before you
grab unconsciously for your phone and
start changing your chemicals in your
body it would be such a great idea to
sit down and before you start your day
just review the thoughts you don't want
to think
review the behaviors you really want to
change about yourself just review them
just go over them in your mind re review
the emotions that you feel the most in
the day and just remember that those
emotions aren't loving to you just just
review them in the beginning just so
that you're aware of them if the changes
you'll start becoming aware of them and
when once you can observe them you're no
longer the program once you're conscious
of them you're no longer unconscious
right you're out of the program
before you start the day ask yourself
what how do I want to think today how do
I want to feel how do I want to behave I
mean what would greatness look like what
would love look like today what could I
do
that would be really cool for me at the
end of the day say wow so I had a good
day today what what would make me feel
that way and if you can't find an answer
to that start reading who reads anymore
read a book I read so many books a week
I know I'm that way too so read
something about you want to be wealthy
read a book about someone who became
wealthy and get real and realize they
may have failed 50 times before they
actually pulled it off or what were
their characteristics what were their
traits What made them it's not wasn't
about their wealth it was about who they
became that's the key right so so so
fill your brain with a little knowledge
and then just start asking yourself
what's the greatest expression of myself
that I can be today and and and rehearse
it rehearse how you're going to be and
and then if if it leads to a different
Choice that's the unknown and just know
that it's not going to be predictable
it's going to be a little uncomfortable
that's where the magic happens if you
can stay relaxed and awake in the
unknown
things get pretty exciting when you're
back to the known you're back to the
familiar don't expect anything to change
in your life and if you say it's that
person or that circumstance
ah you defaulted went back to the
program of the victim allowing your
outer environment controlling your
thoughts and feelings if you truly do
this well
this is what I discovered
if I truly feel the feelings of my
future before they occur and I live in
that state I'm no longer looking for it
to happen how could I look for it if I
feel like it already has right so I try
to stay in that state because then I
don't then I'm not separate from it and
that tends to be when the magic happens
there there's no control anymore there's
no predicting there's no perfectionism
there's none of all there is is just
kind of an experiment like I'm
experimenting to see if I changed my
thoughts and feelings if my life will
change and that should be the experiment
everybody has and and and do it with
with curiosity and do it with just
seeing if if the experiment works if it
doesn't change something else about
yourself until it starts to work also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something thing the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is start your day
with a run with David Goggins what does
a morning look like for you at the
moment if you've got a routine of some
kind yes I run every single morning
about five five thirty so every morning
starts with the Run and that's because
that's the one thing I hate to do more
than anything in the world
so that's like my cup of coffee
and I'm all about armoring yourself
so the second you leave your house
and the second you open your phone the
second you do any of that you are now
letting in poison in cancer
so I make sure a lot of things you can't
avoid
so as I get up I start to armor plate my
mind and body like a person's going to
war you put your body armor on that's
what I'm doing on that run
I'm waking up and I'm giving myself all
this armor so when I come out in the
world now look at that phone I'm ready
I'm not waking up late I'm not rushing
around I'm not disorganized because I
know I'm gonna get hit in the mouth
there's a there's an art to getting hit
in the mouth
and that is why these things are
important you have to wake up and you
have to give yourself belief you have to
give yourself confidence that it starts
with that run rule number five is do the
miracle morning routine with Hal Elrod
arguably the single most important
Improvement I can make in my life to
improve my life is to upgrade my morning
ritual or to create a morning ritual and
the idea is that how you we start our
day sets the tone and the context and
the direction for the rest of the day
and therefore our life and if you win
the morning you win the day if you start
the day by putting yourself in a
physical mental emotional and spiritual
State you are a better version of who
you were when you went to bed the night
before and if that's how every day
begins you enter the day energized and
clear and and ready to go on fire and so
I decided okay if I'm gonna do the
morning ritual I'm gonna create the
ultimate morning ritual like I want this
to be I I I'm so I was so tired at six
months into this downward spiral I was
depressed I was I was everything I was
just falling apart and so I created
these six practices which we'll dive
into today and uh they I didn't know how
to do any of them like one was
meditation I had never meditated in my
life one was affirmations I thought
affirmations were really goofy like what
do you just you pump yourself up you
know and uh but I but the next morning I
woke up an hour earlier than normal
which the interesting thing was I
thought it was going to be hard because
I wasn't a morning person but it was
actually like I was a kid on Christmas
Eve the night before I was so excited to
wake up and try this new ritual the
alarm went off the next morning I woke
up jumped out of bed I did the six
practices and I sucked at them I was
terrible like I wasn't good I didn't
know how to meditate I was bad at all of
these things however even poorly
executing this self-care ritual by 6 a.m
I felt so clear I felt so energized
motivated and I felt hopeful and maybe
that's the most important piece because
I believe that one of the major causes
of depression is when you lose hope and
after six months of you know being
optimistic at first eventually life just
beat me down and I got scared and I
didn't know what to do and that very
first day that I did the miracle morning
it wasn't called The Miracle morning but
I did the self-care practice
I I had hope I went wait a minute if I
start every day like this it's only a
matter of time before I'm able to to do
the things I need to do to create what I
want in my life what are those self-care
actions so what are those self-core
actions that you've I mean developed and
refined and practiced and every morning
at 4 30 you get up and you do this every
day no matter what like so just give us
a picture of those what are those
self-care actions so this This Acronym
uh the Savers these are the six
practices that make up the miracle
morning and the first s is for silence
I'll run through these real quick and
then I'll dive into just a couple the
first s is for silence uh that can be
meditation it can be prayer it can be
breathing exercises or for me it's all
of the above every morning for typically
about 10 to 12 minutes the A is for
affirmations these and affirmations I
think have been taught really
ineffectively for I don't know as long
as I've been around
um by teaching us to either lie to
yourself if you want to be happy just
say I am happy until you fake you know
fake it until you make it kind of thing
but I found that the truth will always
Prevail and so if you say I am and it's
followed by something that you do not
believe in your heart you don't resonate
with and you're trying to convince
yourself or trick yourself I think that
can be better than nothing but it's not
the optimum way and we'll dive into the
optimum way here in a few minutes the V
is for visualization the E is for
exercise the r is for reading and the
final s in Sabers is for scribing which
as my good friend JP Sears says is a
pretentious word for writing
um but for the acronym journaling
wouldn't fit at the end of savor just
and rule number six the last one before
some very special bonus Clips is start a
visualization practice with Brendan
burchard think about a major dream or a
major ambition that for some reason
you're like gosh I wish I really stuck
with my sort of actions and routines
more often if you can have that in mind
then this is going to really serve you I
have four ideas for you today the first
idea is to emotionally engage with that
dream each morning of your life
see a lot of people don't actually
struggle with the discipline part in
terms of the doing the thing it's that
they're not getting revved up to do the
thing in other words we got a problem
with motivation not necessarily just
discipline we have a problem with that
once in a while you hit it you do it you
do the work but a lot of times you fall
off because you're not emotionally
engaged in it it's like if you want a
lot of discipline you need a high level
of emotional connection and focus on
that thing that you want to work towards
so every morning what I want you to do
is just start a new visualization
practice
when you wake up in the morning close
your eyes think about the dream the
aspiration the thing that you're really
after in life and just visualize it and
really get yourself emotionally attached
emotionally engaged with it think about
how great it will feel for you to have
that thing or be that thing or
contribute that thing to make that
difference just think about it and allow
it to well up in your heart a little bit
get excited about it remember the dream
that's why we get away from discipline
because we're so busy with the chaos of
the world that we emotionally are no
longer attached in a way that our brain
says hey man focus on this it's
important to you remember so if your
heart is disengaged it's difficult to
stay disciplined
so every morning make it a practice to
actually just imagine the payoff the
benefit the contribution the art the
thing that you do and are doing and do
contribute if you can do that more often
you'll be more fired up and you'll stay
back on track
you wanted to be a professional baseball
player yeah right yep but then you got
an injury I did similar to me so you
never made it to the big league so did
you play minor league I did yeah and I
played division one college baseball too
yeah I like every guy like you and I
talked about this last time it's always
our injuries that ended our careers I
probably it probably put me into a
premature place where I was going
anyways I don't know you aren't going to
be in The Bigs for I wasn't I played
enough baseball with guys who ended up
in the big leagues to know my
limitations yeah so like anything in
life things happen for you not to you
that injury happened for me it certainly
didn't seem like it at the time but it
got me out of that and into something
like what we're talking about now that
completely changed my life so yeah but
yeah I want to be an athlete for sure
all my life all your life that was my
mask and then when it exactly and then
when it ended your identity was like who
am I right yes lost yeah like a lot you
and I were just talking this before we
went on yeah you know our professional
athlete friends were there rare changes
I went into a like anybody like whatever
your dream is when the first one ends it
doesn't happen whether that be a
relationship it could be your marriage
it ends it was a dream right or a
business venture or a sport I went into
a pretty good depression and uh and how
old were you at the time 21 22 and I
ended up you know it's because people
always see the after like the house or
whatever houses or whatever the material
things are but I ended up bad man I
ended up depressed I ended up moving
back at home with my parents I was
living in the city I remember I was
living in this sleeping in the same bed
I grew up in with the same teddy bear
the same posters I was like going back
in time like six years on back where I
was totally unemployed and uh couldn't
find work didn't have the motivation to
get up and find a job just sort of
eating out of their fridge and laying
around all day so that's where I was
many many years ago after baseball and
when you realize things in your life
happen for you truly especially in
hindsight everybody knows it in
hindsight right if you look back at any
disaster tragedy most people look back
five ten years they think that happened
for me that was actually a good thing
and so I was unemployed I couldn't find
a job and my old man my dad was the best
dad role model he could ever have in
your life
hard-working man good man it's better
man than me has more Integrity than me
he's the best man I've ever known but
when I was growing up my dad had a
drinking problem and so my dad had
gotten sober recently and he was going
to these meetings and he comes home from
one of his meetings and says there's a
guy at my meeting who can get you a job
it's right down the street in San Dimas
you're going to be working with kids
doesn't pay anything at six bucks an
hour but you're gonna get this damn job
so show up there tomorrow morning 8 A.M
ask for Tim so I walked out I drive down
there it's a place called McKinley Home
For Boys little did I know that would
alter my entire life that was the most
significant thing that happened to me
and so I walk in there
I said I'm Ed mylette I'm here for the
job you're like what job I'm like I
don't know just my dad told me to show
up here yeah I need to ask for Tim
they're like
we have no idea who the hell Tim is
what's his last name I said I I don't I
don't know his last name and they're
like so you showed up for a job that you
don't know what it is and you don't know
who it is it's hiring you I'm like
here's what I know he's an alcoholic I'm
like oh damn yeah we know that too and
so they bring me to the guy and he says
uh you're hired let's go like literally
shakes my hand and you're hired and he
introduces me to these eight boys that
were my boys they were seven eight and
nine years old and basically I lived
with these boys these precious boys and
we ended up adding a few more my boys
were all Wards of the Court they were
all molested by family where parents
were in prison and so they had no family
and so my whole life changed all of a
sudden these became on this 22 year old
guy these guys become my sons wow and I
did holidays with them I did birthdays
with them I lived with them literally in
a home or like a literally McKinley is a
massive campus full of children that
have been displaced from their homes
that live in individual like Cottages
like a foster care facility massive
though really yeah all boys
it's in San Dimas here and um wow it
just altered my life man because I I'd
been an athlete had a huge ego had that
mask I wanted to compete I wanted to win
I wanted attention I wanted recognition
first time literally in my life I went
while I I love helping people I love
making a difference and my boys were
just come from horrendous situations and
so just I always say this all the time
and I have those eyes too you have them
I think sometimes kids who grow up with
some dysfunction they just have
different eyes yeah they just have these
eyes that are these boys all were
different but they had that same eyes
they're just like man love me believe in
me you know care about me and I had
those eyes because I grew up in an
alcoholic family and my whole life
changed I just went wow I love I
actually love helping people and being
involved in people's lives I didn't know
that because everything was you're great
you're great you know what it is when
you're an athlete right everything's
about you you're amazing free dinners
free this you're a stud all of a sudden
I wasn't a stud and all of a sudden it
wasn't about me it was about these 10
boys that ended up being 10 of them and
it just altered my life man and so after
that I ran into the financial business
that I ended up in but I would have
completely flunked out of that Financial
business had I not been with my boys for
those years and I was there for two
years two years yeah man like eight
hours a day type of thing or sometimes
more sometimes 16 18. I I think about
I'm not kidding you I think about my
boys and my experience there two of them
are still very close with me uh every
day there's a moment where I reflect on
that it altered me completely like what
I wanted to do I always wanted to be
famous and Rich and successful and now I
just wanted to serve yeah I wanted to
help the little did I find out I could
get rich and famous and all that other
stuff I thought I wanted through serving
people every day of Our Lives we live in
a world that is incredibly complex and
you have to remember we all have a two
million year old brain
and it's not designed to make you happy
it's designed to make you survive
so it's always looking for what's wrong
so why would we allow this to be because
it's just a bad habit and so we need a
daily practice and so I want to show you
how I do this for me and I want you to
create your own system based on it this
mind serves me I don't negotiate with it
remember I told you I don't say well
I'll do this well maybe we could do it
maybe we'll jump in the water now it's
like it knows I'm not here to negotiate
when I say it we do it
that's what we want to train ourselves
to do today whenever you want to make a
change or improve something
the first place you want to prove it is
in your mental emotional state
if you do something from a pissed off
state from an exhausted state from a
frustrated state from a weak state it
won't matter what you do the thoughts
are weak when you're in a weak place the
actions are weak so the first thing
we're going to do is I'm going to show
you a simple breathing pattern
and the breathing pattern if you're
familiar with yogas like Breath of Fire
similar to Breath of Fire and it's a
movement here what it's going to look
like is this you're going to sit up in
your chair with energy we're going to
raise our hands up as we take the air in
and then you're going to blow it out
only going to blow out your notes and
we're going to do that over and over
again for 30 breaths you're going to do
this with your eyes closed then you're
going to drop your hands down Palms up
on your weight on your legs and you're
just going to feel whatever you feel you
might notice some tingling
you might notice a sense of peace
it might just feel relaxed and then
we'll do another three sets of ten
another thirty we'll relax and then
another so we're gonna do three sets of
thirty three sets of ten ten ten ten ten
ten ten ten with a break between them
when you're done with that you're ready
to Prime because it puts you in state
priming is three actions it's done in
ten minutes you can do more than ten and
many of you will enjoy it so much you'll
go longer but the reason I do 10 minutes
of priming is I wanted to come up with a
daily discipline there was no excuse not
to do if you don't have 10
minutes for your life you don't have a
life so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna do our three sets of ten three
sets of ten three sets of ten then with
our eyes closed the first three and a
third minutes of the ten minutes is
we're going to focus on three
experiences in our life that we can feel
deeply grateful for three of them and
we're not going to think I'm like oh
this this we're gonna take them one at a
time spend about a minute each and step
into that moment in your life that you
could feel grateful for it could be a
little thing or a big thing it doesn't
matter
what matters is that you go there you
know if I ask you what's it likes to me
on a roller coaster and you remember
time when you're in a roller coaster and
you picture yourself in a roller coaster
over there you're going to give me a
very different feedback than if I get
you to imagine the moment you were going
over the edge and you're in the front
seat then you're going to show me a
different result you want your gratitude
to be in the front seat not an
intellectual gratitude out there so I
take three minutes
a minute each I come up with something
different every time I think of a moment
that I could feel so grateful for a
blessed moment a beautiful moment a
loving moment a sacred moment and I step
in and feel it and flood myself with the
Gratitude gratitude is the antidote to
the two emotions that mess up most
people's lives what are they anger and
what fear those are the two biggies you
cannot be grateful and angry
simultaneously that's the beauty of it
it's the antidote to anger you can't be
fearful and grateful simultaneously so
the more you cultivate and Prime
yourself for gratitude the more you can
push through anger and fear very quickly
and by the way when I do it
I usually pick two strong ones and then
I pick something really simple and I
make myself really feel the Gratitude
like the wind on my face
or the smell of the ocean if I'm doing
it outside by my house or the look on
one of my children's faces and I'll just
fill that up and the reason is
if all you do is get grateful about big
things you're going to miss most of life
after we do our breathing step one of
the three steps first the breathing then
the three steps one gratitude three
minutes roughly a minute each three
different moments you can feel grateful
for and feel it enjoy it favorite live
in it next three in the third minutes
second piece we're going to do is you're
going to feel the energy in you and do a
prayer or a blessing now I know many of
you are not religious I'm not suggesting
you need to be
but almost all of us know there's a
power in love
you know if God was love and we didn't
come up with all the other names for God
you wouldn't have much argument between
people so imagine that what you're going
to do is imagine that energy of God the
universe whatever you want to imagine
coming down into you like a white light
and breathing it down in through your
body down your legs into the Earth and
then coming back up and out again so
it's
and then comes back up
and you don't have to do this with your
hands but I'm trying to show you what
the feeling is and while you're doing
this what you're going to do during
those three minutes is you're going to
give thanks it's like a prayer saying
heal my body my mind my emotions
strengthen me make me the best I can be
strengthen my love my passion my courage
whatever it is that you value in
yourself and you feel that happening of
the three minutes I do that for about a
minute and a half and the other minute
and a half I didn't take that energy
through me and I send it in a circle
around to my children to my family to my
friends to my co-workers to my
associates to my partners to the people
I meet on the street to my clients and
so it's taking the energy and now you
might sound like woo-woo stuff but the
idea of allowing your nervous system to
heal and strengthen just the focus of
that alone for you is strong and sending
to others as well so you can think it's
all but try it and decide based
on the experience if you do it a while I
think you're going to find it'll deepen
that sense of gratitude because it
becomes not only gratitude but healing
is strengthening and a gift to those you
love the last three minutes I call three
to thrive you're going to think of three
things that you really want to
accomplish or achieve but instead of
like hoping it happens or thinking about
it happening you're going to step in
your mind and experience it as if it's
done you're going to see it or feel it
breathe it celebrate it like you've
already achieved the goal what you're
doing is training your reticular
activating system and we talked about
this the other day the part of your
brain that notices things when you
didn't you know before you bought that
car outfit you never noticed them now
you buy that car outfit those cars and
outfits are everywhere how come because
your Ras now that your own one says this
is important I need to pay attention to
this well when you get clear what you
want and you see it as done and feel it
and create it in your mind and your
heart and you celebrate it there's a
sense of certainty then there's your
body and your particular activated
system starts to go to work on making it
happen so you spend a minute each one of
those so basically three minutes each
three and third minutes each and we're
done you need someone who you can trust
like if you're giving someone your money
like or you're trying to take someone's
advice or counsel you need to trust
their intentions all right and so it's
not just whether they have integrity
it's whether they have your best
interest in mind all right so I'm going
to get to how I solve for that in a
second but that is the first character
trait of you need that you need of a
council of somebody of any kind of
council really whether it's investment
law Etc the second
um is efficacy or their skill set right
so let's think of both let's think of
just different scenarios here so let's
say you might trust your mom implicitly
but she doesn't have the skill of
knowing much about you know how to
structure insurance policies or trusts
or you know investments in Tech startups
right you might not have that skill but
you might trust her intention right for
you specifically on the reverse of that
you might see that there's this person
who's got lots of skill is prodigious in
this but it also means that they know
exactly how to screw you if they want to
right which is one of the double-sided
things of being really good at something
right you know all the details you know
how to write the agreement structure the
deals in order to make sure that you you
know get the best outcome right and so
the idea is to find someone who has both
your best interests at heart and has the
ability to deliver on what you want
right and so it's both of these things
and so you're like well yeah maybe that
seems obvious for me just even boiling
it down to that was very helpful for me
because when I look and I look through
advisors look for people I want to get
counsel from I have to look at these two
things all right so here here's how I
test for the Integrity piece and here's
how you can kind of like you can control
for risk here right one is I always try
and interview as many advisors as
humanly possible all right and I do that
because I'm going to get as much
information from each of the council
during this process that will give me
perspective from which to make a
judgment right one of the biggest
problems with this like if you think
about Julie who's trying to lose weight
right she goes to the gym and then she
talks this 10 personal trainers one
personal trainer says it's all about
high fat low carb another guy says hey
don't worry about that keto stuff it's
all about high carb low fat and then
another guy says no you really just need
a balanced thing and another guy says
it's only about calories it's only about
counting your Macros and so you get this
huge perspective so that hopefully you
can make a judgment call otherwise when
you talk to the first guy and he says
it's all about keto then you're like
well I guess this is it right I guess
these guys all have opinions when in
reality there is a truth you just don't
have the perspective in which to make a
judgment yet and so the first step in
this is that I interview as many as I
possibly can from reputable sources so
this is where I reach out to my network
I make posts Etc to try and get as many
referrals as I can alright so that's
step one step two for the Integrity
piece is that I try and have a line
incentives now a lot of times there are
incentive systems that appear aligned
but not are not in reality so let me
give you an example so in the real
estate market if you're a realtor for
example you may think oh this realtor
has my best interest at heart right
because they have an incentive to sell
the house and so that is why they're
going to get compensated so they want to
sell it for as much as possible ah but
they aren't incentivized to sell it for
as much as possible they're incentivized
to sell as fast as possible and get a
deal closed all right and so think about
this for you selling a house for 500 000
that's worth five hundred thousand
dollars is a normal you know that like
that's normal that's the market price
right but for you to make an extra let's
say twenty five thousand or fifty
thousand dollars would be really
material that would be a huge extra
outcome for you you would probably push
a lot harder to get the extra 25 or 50
000 now let's say that um you could
probably sell it in a day at four
hundred and fifty thousand dollars
because it's below the market value of
the house right now here's what's crazy
is that if a a selling realtor you know
like total it might be seven percent two
percent goes to the buyer and five
percent goes to the seller if five
percent is going to your realtor five
percent of five hundred thousand dollars
right is 25 Grand okay and so for them
the the fifty thousand dollar decrease
to drop you from 500 to 450 means that
they're going to give up 2500 so they're
gonna make twenty two thousand five
hundred so let me ask you a question now
the reverse if they sell for 5.25
they're going to get 27 500 right and so
it's a five thousand dollar swing off of
a you know twenty five thousand dollar
nut for them and one of them might take
them three months and one of them might
take them a day so what is their
incentive their incentive is to get is
to is to make as much money as possible
per unit of time and so their
incentivized to sell as fast as possible
and so this is one of those things where
you have to put your thinking cap on and
say are our incentives truly aligned and
so when we're looking at this when I say
there's two aspects that I look for
counselor or somebody who's going to
help me do something financially legally
Insurance wise whatever it is so first
is that Integrity piece and are there
incentives aligned the incentives being
aligned and you could restructure that
deal and say hey you know what you're
going to get zero percent on anything
below 400 000 I'll give you three
percent on anything between 400 and 450
and then from 450 and up I'll give you
20 right or 15 or whatever right and so
now they're highly incentivized to push
and now your incentives are aligned
because each increment for you is worth
almost as much it is to them and that is
how you would align incentives all right
now how do you test for the second thing
which is their skill set this one's hard
all right especially if you don't have
the perspective from which to make a
judgment which when I enter new things
when I'm trying to learn about trust and
I'm trying to learn about investment
things and different Vehicles I'm
learning about storage units more about
multi like you're like oh man there's so
much stuff and there's so much Nuance
that you have to have right and so the
first thing is I like to usually read
two to three books on the topic all
right and I read two to three books just
so I don't appear like an idiot
um and so I can at least understand what
they're saying and they're going to
respect you to they will it's kind of
like defense if you bring your if you
bring at least some level of knowledge
they don't feel like they're going to
take advantage of you so this is this is
the first thing that I do and this is
because I don't like feeling exposed in
these types of conversations the second
thing you can do is if you have someone
that you can trust you can bring them in
alongside you and the third thing that
you can do which is probably the the
most and highest recommended is
repeating the same action I said in the
first hand which is try and talk as to
as many of them as possible and then you
will gather the insights and you'll see
the people who demonstrate the most
expertise and what you can do is take
what one person says and say well what
about this and see what they reply with
right and as you gain gain more and more
knowledge and this is how you so in the
Consulting world this is qualitative
research right this is where you're
literally doing interviews essentially
to gather information so that you can
make an informed decision right and so
when you do these interviews and this is
what this is the lazy part this is what
most people don't do is they won't do
this work right they won't take the time
to interview 20 people or 10 people when
in reality these one decisions the guy
who you decide to you know invest in in
their fund or if you decide to buy this
building or invest in a fund that that
buys X Y and Z right or you'd or you
have somebody who who manages your
portfolio whatever it is right that one
decision can be one of the most if not
the biggest influence on your total net
worth over a long period of time and
people take more time to figure out what
they want to where they want to go on
vacation than where they're going to put
their money right and so my ask to you
is that if you if you put these put
these lenses on think about both of
these lenses lens one do I think this
person is Integris do I think this
person has my best interest at heart and
then two do they have the skill to
deliver on that promise because I don't
want my mom doing my my investments I
know she has my best at heart but she
has no idea what she's doing and then I
don't want somebody who absolutely knows
what they're doing and does not have my
best interest at heart right which
honestly unfortunately is a lot more of
the cases that that you'll come up with
and candidly you know a lot of times
they're literally incentivized against
you you know uh in the insurance
industry they're they're kind of
incentivized to rip you off it's it's
it's pretty terrible and there's a lot
of Industries like that mortgage brokers
are incentivized to rip you off and so
you really have to look at it from both
lenses and these types of decisions can
make the biggest impact on your net
worth and your financial future simply
based on who you decide to work with the
most important part of a morning routine
is how you feel about yourself it's the
number one thing that people do not pay
attention to that matters the most is
how do you feel about yourself when
you're done your morning routine nobody
wakes up perfect nobody wakes up full of
energy yes ready to go wrong I can't
believe today is another day or what a
day to be alive I'm so grateful I like
nobody nobody Mel Robbins Evan
Carmichael Tony Robbins nobody
the difference between where most people
are at and the people who have success
is that they demand
that they show up and they create that
through the routines and the habits
which is your morning routine it's the
easiest way to just get started so you
go from being tired and having stuff in
your eyes and lines on your face and
rolling out of bed to then feeling
inspired motivated ready to take on the
day
how do you do that well
you have to find the thing that actually
makes you feel powerful inspired
motivated confident and ready to go and
most people
just go through the motions and I'm
talking to the Achievers now most of
America most of the world doesn't have a
morning routine at all they fall into
their day they wake up like an accident
and they start falling into what other
people want them to do for the day like
most people wake up and just immediately
go to their phones see the crisis and
they're rushing off to go work on
somebody else's dream they wake up drop
the job that they hate to work on
building somebody else's dream that's
most people you guys watching this
you're probably more on the achiever
side you probably have some kind of
morning routine you're probably doing
more than your friends and the people
around you
the challenge with Achievers and the
morning routine is most of the time
you're going through the motions to just
check the box and feel like I got it
done as opposed to actually getting the
feeling the most important part of a
morning routine is the feeling
so I had on my tour I had a woman
in Albuquerque New Mexico
talk about morning routines and she
asked me what mine was and I told her
what mine was but mine doesn't matter
what matters is what you're doing and so
I asked her what what do you do in your
morning routine well the first thing I
do every day is I pray
okay great so you pray and let me let me
ask you an honest question
I need you to be honest right now it's
important for me for you for everybody
here
how many times when you're doing the
prayer when you've done the same prayer
so many times
when you when you're going through the
prayers how many times are you just
saying the words because you know the
words you've memorized them you say them
a million times
how many times you've just seen the
words
and how many times you actually feel
the Deep connection how many times you
actually feel
power flowing through you
and I figure what the number was it says
40 something like where she actually
feels the power like that's the problem
that's the problem with achievers
you are going through the motions of
your morning routine without without
ever having a Feeling
so that you finish your morning routine
whether it's 10 minutes an hour four
hours however long your morning routine
needs to be
if you don't feel confident alive bold
powerful at the end of your morning
routine then your morning routine isn't
working
I don't care that you check the box of
having done your prayers or watched that
video the number of people who watch a
video but then you're doing it while
you're making your bread or brushing
your teeth or eating breakfast or
whatever you're not ever really
intentional about watching the video
that's great that you can check the box
of saying you watch your video but you
didn't get the feeling so it doesn't
matter if you don't feel more powerful
confident ready to take on the day at
the end of your morning routine then
your morning routine is broken and needs
to be fixed and it's either adding
something new in
that actually makes you feel that way or
just doing the thing that you already
know works but with more intention
so that's what the woman needs to do is
go back and fix the morning routine just
with more intention
we often compare ourselves to other
people and their morning routines the
morning routine envy and say Well
they're doing it so I should be doing it
like that I should be working out like
the rock four hours a day that's
probably not what you want to be doing
the key is figuring out what makes you
happy what is the life that you want to
live understand that your routines
really are set up for you to have the
habits to follow through on success that
you're looking for right success is
habit success is what you do on a daily
basis and your morning routine sets you
up for that so how do we actually then
create a morning routine that works all
right let me let me get practical move
from just inspiring to some tips and you
can actually go off and accomplish
step number one the most important thing
what makes you feel the belief in
yourself
of all the things that you do
that you've tried that you've done what
makes you feel the most belief in
yourself maybe it's watching video like
this is why I design these videos to try
to be a part of your morning routine and
I'm honored for anybody who is is using
these videos uh as that so thank you but
whether it's these videos whether it's
reading the book whether it's meditation
prayer working out getting in nature
petting your cats like what is the thing
that makes you feel belief in yourself
that you're capable of more that today
can be a great day because you're not
don't have the expectations of you
waking up feeling great you won't you're
going to wake up like yes
but what is the thing that you do the
most that has led to you feeling that
love of belief
and you can string together a couple
like when I do this and this and this
and this great
this becomes a seed of your morning
routine
so make that list step number two
is there a sequence to them
what what's the one thing that when you
just start doing that thing it
kick-starts everything else
so that's why making the bed is is
something for a lot of people it's not
that making the bed actually gets you
feel motivated it's that you're the kind
of person who makes the bed and then
it's what happens next is that when you
make the bed you're more likely to then
do the next thing
you're picking something simple as the
first step not because of it actually
doing anything to make you feel great is
that it
makes you do the next step and the next
step and the next step so making your
bread brushing your teeth flossing your
teeth like whatever the thing is
what's the easiest part of the routine
because working out for example working
that's on your list that's hard
you might have lots of energy and
excitement now but tomorrow morning
you're going to wake up and not want to
work out even though you know logically
you know that working out will get you
feeling
not expired inspired hopefully not
expired inspired motivated for the day
you feel great after a workout you don't
want to do the work in the morning
so don't make workout your first thing
something easier that you can fall into
so making the bed
brushing your teeth or if there's
something else drinking a glass of water
like you're the kind of person who
drinks a glass of water in the morning
so then you follow through on the next
thing and the next and the next thing so
you start stacking them
right so step number one is you make a
list of the things that make you feel
the belief the courage and motivation
the fire and you you put that into
routine but step number two is now we're
going to order them and figure it out
what is the easiest best place for me to
get started on these things so that I
can still follow through on everything
else that when I do that one thing
everything else Cascades in order and
then step number three is just make it
realistic
make it realistic you can actually do it
one of the biggest problems that people
have with morning routines
is you create this perfect morning
routine that takes you four hours to do
and it's unrealistic for you to actually
follow through on you'll do it for two
days and then realize wow this is
this is just not happening I'm not I'm
not doing it and what that translates
often is then therefore you suck because
you can't follow the routine therefore
you suck and then the whole day gets
thrown away and the next day and the
next day the next week and next month
nothing ends up happening until you get
inspired for a new morning routine right
so the point of trying on other people's
morning routines or getting some ideas
is really just to figure out what works
for you
for example
uh the whole idea of writing in a
journal
journaling just doesn't do it for me
I've tried it a whole bunch of times I
used to feel bad about myself the
journaling didn't work like why doesn't
work for me what's wrong with me why why
don't I feel better after journaling my
hand gets tired I can't read my own
handwriting I don't know it doesn't
doesn't do anything for me so
after hearing how for how many people
work the work the work the work okay I
commit it I'm gonna I'm gonna do
morning pages and I started writing
whatever comes my mind and if I didn't
know what to write I would write I don't
know what to write I'm just reading what
comes to my mind and having the freedom
just to write that stuff down
but after evaluating I realized this
I feel no better coming out of this
morning routine than I did going in
and if that's the result for you it
doesn't matter that Evan Carmichael does
it or Mel Robbins does it or garyvee
does it or whoever does it it's not
working for you great you can tweak it
test it again try something different
and if it's still not working for you
abandon it and go do something else and
don't feel bad that it's not working for
you it's fantastic go find a thing that
is just because somebody else is doing
it doesn't mean that it's going to work
for you just because that hat fits
beautifully in somebody else doesn't
mean that it's going to work for you
maybe you shouldn't wear hats ever
right
so step one go back to figuring out what
are all the things that you love doing
that make you feel bold confident a lot
the goal of your morning routine again
is to make you feel bold powerful
confident alive ready to take on the day
two you sequence them to figure out
what's the order
so how can you start with the easiest
thing that when you do that thing
everything else Falls in place and then
three make it realistic
make it realistic that is something that
you can stick to that you can do that
will fit into your life it doesn't
require superhuman effort to wake up and
do every day that if you're traveling or
something ends up happening you can
mostly stay consistent on it right make
it realistic for your life what you're
doing because when you can start your
day
with the expectation of not having
energy
right you don't put the fake expectation
of you having to wake up tons of with
tons of energy
but then creating a structure for
yourself
that will bring the energy forward
if you can imagine for the next year
wake up have no energy do something that
will give you energy to show up more
confidently in your life for the day
ahead
imagine how much of a change that will
make in your life if you spent a year
doing that waking up little energy
waking up like you normally do
and then after your routine
after doing a couple things whatever
they are for you being bold powerful
confident alive how does your whole life
change how does your business change how
does your career change how do
relationships change all of it because
you chose to show up with intention by
following those three simple steps
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to end
your laziness and motivate yourself to
work harder check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there you never get better if you're not
willing to put in the time I still grind
I love the grind if you're competing in
one of my businesses I'm gonna kick your
ass because I'm gonna outgrind you
immigrants in America have absolutely